we have this from NBC News what we know
about the slain Texas mall Massacre
suspect Mauricio Garcia Garcia with a
tactical vest was armed with a rifle and
a handgun a senior law enforcement
official said authorities said he was a
suspected Neo-Nazi sympathizer now this
story is it's a tragedy it's unfortunate
and we have unfortunately too many of
these stories that end up happening in
the media I'm sorry that end up
happening and then end up hitting the
media so I mean the first thing I just
want to say before we get into any of
the politics from either side is yet we
don't want these things to happen we
want these things to stop we need to
figure out what the issue is in our
society and our culture I genuinely
believe it's disassociation it is it is
a dejected Society where individuals
don't know or care about each other and
they seek validation or they seek to
push some extremist ideology and then
this whole thing creates a recipe for
disaster and I'll put it simply I think
it's multiculturalism and not the idea
that people of all different types are
holding hands on the rainbow it's that
you have different communities stacked
on top of each other and next to each
other with wildly different views and
they don't like each other and then
people who are crazy will do crazy
things but what ends up happening today
we have the story from the Daily Mail
revealed Texas gunman staked out
Massacre mall to monitor peak times
three weeks before killing eight and
posted details on Russian social media
alongside photos of Nazis guns and
ammunition you see here's where we get
into the psy op
no one knows if this Russian social
media profile is actually but it
actually belongs to this guy a
bellingcat researcher named Eric Toler
just said I found this profile that
looks like it's his in fact I'm pretty
sure he even said I didn't verify it I
don't know now the photos that are
coming out I don't want to show many of
them considering the sensitive nature of
these things they don't show his face
and Ian miles Chong actually found that
most of these photos are from five years
ago on a random subreddit that we're
making fun of these people so the whole
story seems to be strange but let's jump
to this from Andy no
he says the Brown face of white
supremacy a leftist bellingcat writer
has posted screenshots from the
purported Obscure odd how do you
pronounce this
Nikki social media profile of the Allen
Texas mass shooter Mauricio Garcia he's
trying to link the shooter to Tim cast
and Libs of tick tock the account has
photos of random Latino people wearing
or posing in front of Neo-Nazi symbols
balingcat is a government-funded site
that was sourcing from intelligence
agencies it employs radical leftist
writers and then I think I've got uh do
I have Ian miles Chong here
Ian miles Chong says posting on Blue Sky
Media Matters for America registered
Parker Malloy tells former Twitter uh
trust and safety head yellow Roth that
not Banning Libs of tick tock may have
caused the Allen Texas mass shooting and
then we have this so stupid now now we
know well this is the left argument for
everything shut up or there will be more
mass shootings don't say your point or
there will be more mass shootings that's
their argument that's all it is the
whole point is they want to connect the
anyone that would speak in a way that
they do not approve of and which is
essentially their in control of they
want to link them to any kind of bad
thing that they can I mean you look at
timcast and you know it was swatted 15
times last year here and and they're
saying that plus bomb threats yeah and
they're saying that that Tim cast is
causing stochastic terrorism even though
they continue like the there's leftists
that are constantly saying oh Tim cast
does this and they do this and blah blah
it's like it's literally the iron law of
woke projection can we can we change the
name researcher to propaganda because I
think it's more accurate and it feels
more genuine if we just let's just call
it what it is what they are you can't be
a researcher for Belling cat or Media
Matters if you have an agenda if you're
whole you're pushing an agenda yeah if
your whole job is to to look for people
that have a different political opinion
and then cast them in the most negative
light imaginable you're not a journalist
you're not a researcher you are a
propagandist so they're leftist
propagandists they're just commies
they're just I mean they're just commies
I I I really just don't care because I
think they they've just lost I just I I
feel nothing of this well they're
they're at the ad hominem level right
they're attacking they're attacking you
they're saying You must be obviously
affiliated with I thought by the way the
uh the Brown face of white supremacy was
Larry Elder I'm pretty sure we have the
black face yeah oh there's a big
difference there this is the brown error
on your part but it's okay yeah end of
the day though when they start getting
into the the ad hominem attacks like
they've already lost the argument there
is no fundamental argument against it
they're gonna attack your character
they're gonna attack your your values
but it doesn't have anything to do with
what like did they make a strong point
where they think this guy was somehow
there there was a four episodes where
the media had enough influence to where
I may have been concerned about this and
then been like oh do I got to put out a
statement I remember when uh New Zealand
shooting happened and the guy said
subscribe to PewDiePie or whatever right
and then PewDiePie was all like yo oh
man like hey look John I'm kind of just
like shut up I look at this and I'm like
shut your mouth Belling cat you guys are
idiots you get me swearing but
like it's a it's a random profile from
Russia The credibility is almost nothing
and there's four clips from one show one
time and so I just look at this and I'm
like let me tell you all a story about
when the Southern Poverty Law Center
found a holocaust denying conspiracy
theory website from Iran that listed me
as a speaker I have never been to Iran
and then claimed that I was a speaker
and they had to retract and delete it
and apologize because the best part the
best part was this me and a few other
people threatened a lawsuit saying like
how could you just say this ridiculous
fake garbage and they knew typically
when it comes to defamation lawsuits
they're really hard but what they would
have to say is either they knew it was
fake or me uh Southern party Law Center
believes that Holocaust denying
conspiracy websites based in Iran that
were previously deleted and then hosted
as an archive are credible sources of
information that they rely on and I was
like I'd be willing to accept them
winning the case if they state that
publicly that would be fantastic yeah
you know they come out and say we we do
often find Archives of conspiracy theory
websites based in Iran as and and use
that as relevant facts for our sourcing
so I look at this and I just say one
thing wow they must be really desperate
the the transgender shooter in Nashville
must have terrified them to the Bone
because the other day when we were in
Miami I was hanging out at Hard Rock
Seminole and this is what people were
talking about you hear what just
happened and in you know in Texas and I
was like yeah and then someone goes and
that Nashville thing with that that
transgendered person and I'm like oh
when a regular dude who doesn't know a
whole lot about anything is talking
about that stuff you can see exactly why
they're freaking out well this is the
apple of discord too right so it's it's
that Golden Apple it says to the fairest
it's just a shiny object they toss it in
the middle of the room it doesn't have
to have any meaning behind it other than
whatever you ascribe to it and people on
the left have ascribed exactly what they
want to feel they fill in all the blanks
it doesn't matter that it's weak Russian
it doesn't matter that it's not
backstopped that's what we call that in
the intelligence world there's no
backstop behind it right it doesn't go
deep enough for there to be any kind of
validity and yet it says what I wanted
to say yeah it pegs my enemy in the way
that I wanted to Peg them so it's
effective and nobody looked into it any
further because they don't care they're
not trying to find truth what they're
trying to find is am I reaffirmed in my
belief whether it's that they hate you
or that they hate uh you know that it's
it's obviously guns and white supremacy
and all the other things that they're
gonna demonize I don't just toss that
shiny object in there I I I really do
Wonder like what is the what is the end
the goal of of trying to claim this guy
was a fan of Libs of tick tock or Tim
cast it has nothing to do with us what
band what why would we get banned I know
I I think it would be ridiculous for
them to ban you but that's exactly but
that's the angle that they're trying to
go with that's why they're talking about
it that's why your enemies are
continually bringing this up I just I
disagree I disagree I get your point
admit maybe that's the intention but
it's just like there's literally nothing
they can do the the it is it doesn't
work that way with Alex Jones they
desperately try to find anything and
this was several years ago but the media
has lost so much
power and influence they may as well be
posting this I mean they're literally
posting it on they don't know it no
they're on Blue Sky it's like do we know
do you guys know what blue sky is no no
no you've never heard of it okay well
you do I do but the average person's
like I haven't Tim I know you're talking
about yeah this is a cartoon all right
jack dorsey's new thing yeah they're on
some obscure website spitting into the
wind and it's laughable but I got
coverage in the Daily Mail they don't
mention me or lives of tick tock okay so
the thing that's fun about it I mean
obviously they're trying to accomplish
an agenda and they also haven't realized
that they've lost all their Capital so
they're spending money that has no value
right so they're out there spending this
they're attempting to do something with
this sort of website with this sort of
story but it doesn't get any traction
but it used to and they're doing the
same thing it's like it's like a toddler
that's still throwing Tantrums when you
know that they're not going to pass out
they're not going to die if they pass
out so you're letting them pass out so
now they're throwing the Tantrums and
those Tantrums come out exactly what
you'd expect it's like we're just gonna
watch you until you stop there's no
there's no outcome to this that's going
to be beneficial so exactly but who
cares like let them let them I got some
direct messages from people and they
were like whoa what's going on and I was
like I always tell people don't send me
stuff when people like I I've got so
many people saying so much stupid crap
about me all day every day I literally
don't care you know today you know what
what are we doing I'm having some sea
bass for dinner complaining on the
internet that's about it this is
meaningless it's it's unfortunate what
happened in Texas but the left is
looking for any kind of political angle
you take a look at what happened after
Nashville they claimed the trans person
was one of the victims exactly they're
trying desperately to spin this thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time